my first guest was the star of the tv
series peewee's playhouse and the
hilarious film peewee's big adventure
his new hbo special the pee wee herman
show on broadway premieres march 19th
please welcome pee wee herman
[Applause]
hello
i'll be right there
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey
come on
[Applause]
that was an incredible interest
sex nothing like water skiing
and you're dry as a boner
[Laughter]
so nice to have you here
thank you you know one of my favorite
things whenever you come to visit me you
always bring a special toy or a gadget
something that's amusing you recently
and i will not let you down tonight okay
oh it's right here yeah what do you got
there oh it's it's called the phony
phone get off the phone phony phone
ringer excuse if you're on the phone and
somebody's jacking away you're trying to
get off the phone you push these
different buttons you know you go like
oh i'm sorry i have to get off the phone
[Applause]
this one i can't figure this one this is
for static and you're crying
i'm saying what i can't hear you i can't
hear you i have to call you back okay
uh-huh what else you got there
[Music]
someone's at the door tell us at my door
i hope they don't wake up the baby i
hope they don't wake up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
shut up
shut up daddy's gonna freak out shut up
here listen to this one
[Laughter]
it works every time it works really good
i love that okay well what else did you
bring for us peewee i got one more thing
here i wanted to show you it's my
balloon trick do you mind if i stand no
not at all it's your pee hermit you do
what you want yeah
okay balloon trick
i'd like to see this
all right
i wish we could blow the balloon up
first
[Laughter]
this is my favorite part
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right
yes
[Music]
please stop it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just kidding